hi i'm isaac from the boston data
science meetup group
um yeah and tonight uh we obviously have
elaine sadler talking
a couple quick things um yeah the boston
data science group sponsored by
massmutual so
we thank them for helping to sponsor the
event
um great to do a kind of uh co-hosting
with
pi data boston i actually for a while
ran a pie data chapter up in orono maine
so i always get to host with pi data
groups
um so anyway so getting to our speaker
so elaine sadler
definitely has an interesting talk
coming up tonight on ai
quality control framework so lane is
uh from it has a background and is
currently working
on this open source framework
to manage some of the problems with deep
learning and quali
deep learning and kind of
reproducibility which is a very big area
and kind of
the quality of machine learning models i
think anyone who's in particular worked
with deep learning
um has run into a lot of problems
uh managing hyper parameters uh
tuning models and making sure the models
uh
run correctly uh in a production context
so um so it's always good to see a talk
that addresses it um
so um so yeah with that said uh i'll
hand it over to wayne and um hopefully
we learn a lot about that his aiqc
framework and how i can help with those
problems
all right thank you so much for the
intro guys and um
and thank you for hosting the meeting
i'm going to go ahead and
grab the old screen share so
just a quick little agenda um
first things first we'll talk through
some slides about the uh the
origins and challenges that i was
looking to solve in
building this framework um then we'll
take a quick look at the documentation
you can figure out how to install it you
know look at what the difference between
the high level api and the low level api
is
you know github repos right here any
stars
much appreciated and then finally if
time allows we'll go through a demo of
the high level api
on either some image data or some some
kepware
satellite data for tabular so here's
a high level look at the framework what
it does is it helps you rapidly prepare
data in the form of splitting and
folding
and then rapidly encoding
just by setting simple variable names
and then after that it breaks the single
model paradigm
by allowing you to hypertune models in
batches and then finally it
automatically calculates performance
metrics
and charts for all of that and
the goal in doing so was really just to
take a lot of the tedious manual code
out of the process of deep learning both
the preparation of the data
and training of models just because
you know i was working on a paper and i
was trying to
you know show comparative metrics and i
was you know using some remote server
and i was like this is just getting
absolutely out of hand so um how could
someone that's really new to the space
go in and do a good job
and at the same time i've been working
in genomics as a product manager in the
analytics space
with uh big pharma on national biobank
projects to look for
drivers of rare disease and i was just
kind of going away that
they weren't using machine learning they
weren't using deep learning it wasn't
even discussed
they were still using um statistics
um and you know pretty early forms of it
so i was wondering you know what what
are some of the challenges that are
holding
researchers back from adopting deep
learning and
when you think about it it's really
pretty simple
you know most of the researchers i've
been working with have been
phds and they're biologists and doctors
they're not
programmers you know scientists doesn't
necessarily mean
data scientists and it definitely
doesn't mean software engineer right so
i think you know the the emergence of
informatics in each
space we're going to start to see that
change and you know it'll work it's
way more into education but for now most
of the people i was working with they
really were yearning for
a user interface where they could just
you know
click a few buttons and run their models
right and
the other side of that is not only that
were they not programmers but they
weren't machine learning
experts and this is you know again not
to slam any people these are some of the
smartest
people in the world and also if i bring
up a competitive technology
um you know i'm trying to toe the line
with code of conduct and i'm just
bringing it up for like a survey of
methods out there
finally when you do dig into machine
learning and deep learning it really
is pretty loosely defined if your script
lines up nicely um you won't get errors
deep in your um training runs but it's
pretty easy to run into that kind of
scenario if you don't really know what
you're doing and when you contrast that
to
like quality control processes and
science you can see how
they would view machine learning as a
black box and then finally
you know not everyone has the money to
work with a a data robot
or use cloud-based methods a lot of
people are still using you know
on-premise hpcs so this creates a real
challenge
that prevents the adoption of deep
learning at a time when like we have a
lot of problems to solve
here on earth so i was thinking to
myself could i come up with some
you know some bumper rails around this
process to make it easier so that it can
be
uh adopted at a higher rate and i was
coming at this from
a django perspective where everything
was like nbc so i had a lot of
experience there
and at the same time we were using
jupiter at work and i was learning data
science so it all just kind of naturally
came together into a nice framework i
had also been
working on my own paper so i had access
to some
some academic guidance i was looking at
neural networks as graph data structures
with edges and nodes just like any other
graph and i was trying to
make more informed predictions based on
that information so i got
access to um you know i saw the highest
council my order and they said
you know you do you're doing great but
you can't really have a paper if you're
not using validation splits
or cross folds and i need to see you
know comparative evidence of every run
that you've done
if you actually want to you know publish
this paper so
i kind of viewed that as a quest right
to go out and learn some of the best
practices
of deep learning and i found these three
chronic
problems riddled and hard-coded into
pretty much
every solution out there and we're gonna
step through
some of these in action but um there are
a lot of sources of bias and they don't
necessarily have to do with how training
is done it's more
about how the data is prepared and
that's why i chose to focus on that
initially i was looking at can i just
come up with a way to
you know functionalize my model and pass
in hyper parameters nicely because
everything else seems kind of complex
but
i was naturally drawn towards these
problems and data so
you know the first is that fundamentally
we've been evaluating on our test split
so you know let's say you run your model
and it is doing some learning like
you're above 50
and you see you've got 74 accuracy in
your test
pretty decent learning on your training
data and you make some changes
and you see okay yeah they're both going
up but
i it looks like i've got a pretty good
model but it's it's not doing
perfect on the test so again you make
more changes
and you know the the problem with this
is that you're biasing you're you're
over
fitting you're you're effectively using
your entire
data set to train your model which
really defeats the purpose of
splitting up the data in the first place
so
um i'd call this evaluation bias and
it's it's kind of
unavoidable because we are humans and
we're looking at you know this kind of
process
and we're making our own model in the
back end that says you know these params
are giving you this
and this is coming from the latest book
on fast ai they've got a lot of great
theory out there um so that's kind of
the first one and if you want to solve
this
the problem is that validation splits
are really they're they're
second class citizens they're not widely
used this is the classic 70 30 split
using you know the train test split that
everyone's familiar with
and if you want to do this and introduce
a validation split then
you have to kind of run it twice
basically and
this introduces math which is
lame in the python world at least
and then if you take this further
downstream and you look at how data is
actually being
encoded um let's say you are using
something
like cross fold validation where you're
rotating which fold you're using to
evaluate your model
and then finally you're running it on
the test split
a lot of what i saw was that people were
just encoding the entire
data set so all this aggregate
information
from both test and validation is being
leaked
into it's actually transforming the
training data so your averages
your um your power transforms your
scaling it's
it's all um biasing the training data
so that's that's the the leakage problem
right and
these are very they're chronic problems
they're everywhere
and this is just like if you wanted to
actually uh do it properly you would
encode
each each split or fold independently
so that you're not sharing information
across them
and then finally i mentioned the oral
history of machine learning right so
when you get started pretty much every
data type
is handled differently like we were
talking about images and natural
learning and time series
it's all practically a different science
and then
um each data type is um
follows it its own different protocol
and this is kind of what i'm talking
about if you look at scikit
learn and the encoders i love kindler
right i use this in ai qc
but the columns to represent different
data types
and then on the left-hand side are the
different
encoders that you can use at least the
ones that are in
capitalized letters and then a 1
represents if it works and a zero
represents if it doesn't work
so there's a lot of trial and error in
figuring this out
um additionally like some of these allow
you to modify data in place
some of them don't so you have to handle
the data differently so
these present challenges to newcomers
i remember the first time i was like
what i have to encode my data i can't
just
you know throw it into some magic model
these are problems that people fade
and then finally um what i was
originally going to solve was training
and scoring models by hand
and what i found was that there are some
good solutions out there
um but i if i thought about this and i
said i don't want evaluation bias i
don't want data leakage so am i going to
have to manually feed in
crossfolds individually and
what does the setup look like for this
i'll show that in the next slide because
these solutions that i was running into
they really felt like they were intended
for programmers not
people that were trying to do science
and then finally
they focus more so on the data just kind
of shows up
right and then you're only focusing on
the parameters in the model itself so
here's kind of
the you know the different um starting
points this was step one in the process
and
it was you know setting up yaml files
and
it just seemed like a lot of programming
like parent run and child run i still
don't really know
what that is i'm assuming there's some
kind of branching going on but
not great for a biologist um and
yeah here just to show some praise i
think you know weight symbiosis did a
great job in just
having a really simple callback for uh
recording your weights there's a lot of
different
things you can do with callbacks and
then ray tune
you pass it in a config it's got some
nice hyper parameter optimization and
you give it your training function but
again
where's you know where's the data right
it and the the problem that i have with
this
is it has it's mainly nomenclature right
i'm so sick of seeing
x and y i always forget what they are
just call them features and call them
labels
and that right there was kind of the the
basis for aiqc
and treating things as objects like a
feature a label a data set a split set
an encoder set um just because
it's it's all just scripting and
if you only look if you you show up with
the data this you have no history of the
data like
if it if you told your high school
science teacher that
i don't know i used like 70 of the
samples
is that shouldn't fly and that shouldn't
fly for the fda
right if you want to actually take data
science seriously you need to have
a good reproducible workflow when it
comes to data lineage
so i made this framework um on the
bottom right you can see
it's just a downloadable python package
you pip install aiqc
it acts like an mvc framework in that
there's objects for everything that you
would expect like a feature in a label
and a data set
like i mentioned and those all get
recorded in a local sql light database
that you don't even have to set up it
just
when you import the package it
automatically gets
it creates a file and creates tables
within there and you can just start
working with the objects and we'll see
we'll take a look at the high level api
but in literally two
you know it's effectively two lines of
code even though there's a lot of
variables
you can ingest your data sets split and
fold them and encode them
run them and run a model in batches with
hyper hyper parameters
and we'll see how it spits out all the
metrics then you know maybe someday i'll
make an enterprise product
out of it too but for now i'm just
having fun uh
you know adding support for new data
types so
from here are there any questions i have
i don't have the
the chat up but i you know there aren't
that many of us so i would like to field
questions if people
do have them i don't see any put into
the chat
at this point in time but if anyone has
any go ahead and put them in the chat
or we can take them at the end as well
okay great great so the framework itself
right now it supports
tabular data and image data doesn't yet
support text and graph data
i think time series is just going to be
3d tabular
and then right now it supports
classification
both binary and multi-class
and then also regression or
quantification
and it supports keras right now in the
future it'll be really easy to add
support for pi torch just because i'm
pickling
models so they're just kind of serial
about serialized
strings and functions basically but
this is the documentation portal aiqc
dot read the docs
you do a pip install aiqc
import aiq and then this one liner right
here
is going to create a it uses apters
so this is what application support
looks like this is where you're supposed
to be installing applications not just
at like the very
root but you can see if i navigate into
the aiqc folder
there's a sqlite file and oh i'm not
sharing that screen
but anyways we've got a few questions
popping up do you want to
talk sure yeah yeah that'll that'll
break up
a little bit okay we got a couple from
adam one of the cohort cohort
co-organizers from the other the boston
data science group are there any
libraries you tried to use that weren't
quite what you were looking for when you
decided to build
your own library any libraries that you
tried to use that weren't quite what you
were looking for
yeah so i fundamentally fundamentally am
not a big fan of sql alchemy so i was
looking for an alternative to that
and i wanted to use django but
the interface with jupiter is not really
that fluid
so i ended up using i'll just type it
into the chat and it's kind of
embarrassing and the author thinks it's
embarrassing but the library is called
peewee and it's an ora
um it's and it's stress simplicity so
it makes it really easy to interact with
a sql light file which is just
a sql database as just a file so there's
no ports there's no shenanigans there's
no binary install or anything like that
it's really easy and really nice to work
with so i highly recommend it
let's see can you explain the difference
between keras
and pi torch so keras is just a high
level api
for tensorflow when you try to interact
with the tensorflow api
it's kind of it's kind of greek and it's
hard to do in you know native python i
feel
at least so keras just really boils that
down into a sequential
model um that you know by torch
they're starting to become one and the
same and you can pretty much kind of use
them the same they're going to have the
same type of layers the same type of
hyper parameters so that is is more so
but a lot of people gravitate towards pi
torch
because it's it's highly custom and you
can get really
in depth with the functional api
um whereas keras is designed
more so as a high level api so that's
why you know the legit people use pi
torch but
i know i've had pretty good luck with
keras and
when you talk to people a lot in the
field they're doing this kind of work
a lot of them are still even just using
tensorflow so
there's that am i looking for developers
to contribute to the project
absolutely yes i forgot to say that at
the start
i actually can't join pi data as a solo
contributor so
i welcome people um wholeheartedly
if you're interested in natural language
processing not an area i have much
expertise at
if you're interested in working with
time series data or generative models
um yes um absolutely
welcome and um yeah just feel free to
send me an email
and i'll put that in in the chat right
now um
when you say keras that means there's no
specific use of tensorflow
not right now no but they handle model
pretty much to add a support for a new
um
for a new library i just have to handle
the model output objects and i just got
keras done because that's what i use and
i kind of
moved on but yeah definitely need to add
support for that can this be
incorporated into standard qa and bd
testing frameworks
it's just a python library literally so
uh i don't
see why why it couldn't and then the
fact that it's just a sqlite database
and you don't need some kind of weird
connection
means that if you have a file system you
can you can work with it
yeah um the examples look
more like psychic learn pipelines is
there anything yeah so
anything fundamentally different other
than using cross
so i think that is kind of a good point
to jump into
to just jump into the demo
right so if i pull up so this is
a running jupiter lab instance right
and if i come in here into this
this let's do yeah let's start
here just because it'll be simple and
it's built in
so i've got some example data sets built
into into the package
and i'm going to go ahead and import it
and make sure it's all
working it's a decent amount of code
and i'm going to import some libraries
it looks like
so within the datum module i've got a
bunch of
data sets already built in so i'm just
going to grab this one
it's kind of a classic um binary
classification example so you can see
it it's pointed up right here and then
maybe let's start with the high level
ipi because that's a good place to start
but
when you when you feed data into
something like scikit-learn you're
really just
giving it like a numpy array right
um and when you give it a label
you're dividing it into like x and y and
i introduce a few wrappers around that
like
label and feature set that's probably
the simplest example
but there's there's an object for pretty
much every every kind of action that you
want to take
so it's it's it's a guided experience so
all of the um
commands you would need to run can be
boiled down into one one call to
pipeline and then when you're making
a model in experiment when you when you
have an algorithm you give it a bunch of
hyper parameters
and feed it into the experiment honestly
i looked at um
psychic line pipelines in it a few years
ago and
like three months ago and it just didn't
feel intuitive to me it just didn't feel
it felt almost it felt like it
um the library wasn't originally
designed to do that and it felt like it
was kind of being forced to do that so i
said can i take
you know kind of a fresh approach on it
using its great encoders
and using its great um splitters and
crossfolds
but then like when i do something like a
split or a cross fold
i'm recording the indices of each
and then persisting that so i'll just
let's let's take a look at what that
actually looks like
here so if you're
to take this data frame the sonar data
set
with all you know the labels and the
feature sets
what you do when you create a pipeline
as you specify the type of data that
data that you're making and you pass it
either
the file path um it supports csv
tsv parquet and
i really like parquet because it
preserves d types very well
but you can also give it a pandas data
frame or
an nd array and what
it wants you to do is tell it you know
which column is the label
and then the high level api just assumes
all the remaining
columns are features it lets you specify
the size of your validation split
and your test you don't have to split
the data manually it's just going to
split it and record that
as um as a split set
and then if you wanted to do um
cross-fold validation
you would just say five here and if you
wanted to do
um stratified binning you would just say
like you know three stratified bins
there so it is using it is like an
abstraction layer for cycle
so i can learn um when it comes to
the data processing um i love it i think
it's very powerful
and then if you want to encode the label
you pass in
a scikit-learn encoder like an actual
scikit-learn encoder that i've just
imported up here and
it if you try to do something wrong like
if you try to
use a numerical encoder on a categorical
it won't let you it'll it'll actually
error to help
users out and then you can pass in an
entire dictionary of feature encoders
and so here you can see you can either
rule columns
in or out so and you can chain them
together
and so if you have to split up your data
it will actually join them back together
so you can run
many different encoders based on the
type of data that are in your features
so here i'm using a power transformer
and i'm saying only target
the float data type um
yeah so let's go ahead and run it and
it'll it'll
tell you it'll it'll actually go and
so that you don't get an error when
you're training it'll test
the encoding of each column
and if you're out of columns it won't
let you add more encoders right so
there's
these are the kind of validation rules
that i've been
introducing on top of it um
here i let's see um so the
next thing you want to do is build an
algorithm so a bit
like pi torch lightning i actually know
pytorch lightning existed but
you divide the model up into the build
phase
uh the train phase and then you give it
hyper parameters and then you pack it
into an algorithm object
and then you feed that into an
experiment it allows you to parameterize
it
i haven't added transfer and learning
support to this yet so
you could ultimately skip the model
build and model train
and do like a fast ai type approach
where you're just using pre-trained
models
so if we define this model here and then
we define what training looks like you
know the batch size
the number of hyper parameters to run we
might get an error because i haven't
actually checked these hyper parameters
and made sure they still line up with
the model
but again it's just pickling these
objects
and then it's going to access them later
and it's going to pass these hyper
parameters in
as keyword arguments so you can do
really really nifty things
like um here i was trying to test an
activation of nikki
relu versus relu just using an if
statement um
and in this convolutional example over
here
you can see uh you can get really
creative and say like i want to use this
many
blocks and just treat that as a hyper
parameter
like here i've got con blocks to use
so it makes it really expressive and you
can treat the entire topology
pretty much as a parameter but let's see
if we can go ahead and
actually run this so previously before
python 3.8 um i was running this as
a background process but now it just
runs on a foreground process but
i mean that's kind of how everything
else works anyways
so while that trains in the background
let's take a look at some of the metrics
so this is running
all the jobs based on the hyper
parameters that i specified
and the metrics get automatically
calculated for every single
split so if i'm using a train validation
test
split it's going to calculate metrics
for each of those
independently and you can say hide test
if you
wanted to get really strict about
evaluation bias
here is an example of some of the
some of the plots that are automatically
produced behind the scenes for every
single run
you have something that helps you
compare entirely different
runs so because i was generating so many
different runs i needed a way to compare
um across models
right so this is an entire model the
train the validation
the test and then this is a different
model the train the validation the test
i call this the boomerang chart
i haven't really seen it elsewhere you
can you can again everything's
persistent right so you can just say
show me the hyper parameters that were
used
um getting this id i'm getting this run
by id
the the learning curves are all recorded
so you can see what's going on these
charts are all interactive
and if i'm running a regression i'm
going to get different
different plots automatically generated
based on the type of analysis
that based on the type of analysis that
i'm conducting
so here and there's there's even
different metrics too
right so classification and regression
are handled kind of
entirely differently but let's take a
look at
i'm going to interrupt this run right
here
and just to show you like boom
for the jobs that we've run
these are all the metrics and
i can set a threshold for
performance and loss again based on the
type of analysis that's conducted
different metrics are used
and i can just visualize so yeah this
totally bonked on the test looks like
maybe it's
it's not um it it lends itself to
interpretation
of models pretty nicely so again i'll
stop there
um the repo is github.com
aiqc if you're interested
in getting in touch and collaborating so
thank you so much for the time
awesome thank you so much lane and we
we do have uh uh one more question so
far that's been
put in also from uh adam again uh
you mentioned before that you are uh you
are accepting
uh collaborating with other developers
you have any low hanging fruit issues or
easy things for someone to work on who
might want to contribute
you know the first thing that comes to
mind is
feature importance or even adding
support for pie torch again because it's
just kind of like pickling objects
handling the binary file and writing it
into
uh sql light so that's
that's definitely more than welcome
another one that comes to mind is
imputation right so if there's missing
values i'd like to have
um like an imputer set similar to the
way that there's an encoder set
so people could just kind of drop a
drop something in there
yeah thank you for asking awesome
yeah any other questions we have
this is our question answer time so
if there are any any questions either
put them in the chat or
you can unmute yourself and just ask
them verbally
so just take a minute see if there's any
more questions to come up for
anyone it was a great talk lane thank
you
so much thank you again for again for
having me
it's like a really um i've got a
question that's all right
go ahead well thanks uh hi i'm um i'm a
tester i'm always interested in that
perspective
from the qa perspective uh i'm just
wondering if you've had any i mean
it's i assume it's easily done because
it is just a python library but have you
had any examples or anyone you've heard
of use the tool to integrate it into
saying ml ops pipeline or a devops
pipeline
sort of thing integrating it no i mean i
literally just finished writing it a few
a few weeks ago and just said hey let me
come up for water and see what's going
on and
think about how to position it and you
know
if i would say this is almost for an
organization that's pre
ml ops and this could kind of serve as
an ml ops
solution where they're thinking about
getting into deep learning maybe
their analysis is kind of static and
they don't necessarily need to have like
a very fluid real-time pipeline that's
pulling data on a schedule into models
but
um it could sit in there and you could
use any
again it's just a python package with
different uh modules so you could use
different aspects of it
in your pipeline like if you didn't want
to use the data pipeline maybe you could
skip that part unclear
on but writing tests is another area
where
i could use help um i just kind of wrote
like a test stop pi
and ran through all the examples and i
run them
when i write new code so um you know
something like pi test
could be very helpful
i'm unclear on how you overcome the
evaluation
bias issue can you expand on that yeah
sure
so um in the low level api
um there's
um i'm going to share screen
it always shows you like a thousand
windows you know so
when you're creating in the low level
api if you're creating a batch of jobs
manually you can say hide test
and what that is going to do is it's
going to
it's going to keep your holdout data
out of the metrics and out of the charts
so you won't even know
you'll get performance metrics on your
your train and you'll get performance
metrics on
your your validation split
so um there you're just
taking a small slice and then you're
if you're getting good performance on
both your train and your validation
split
then it's it's more likely that
your model is going to generalize well
when you
throw it at the unseen holdout split
and again you don't have aggregate
transformations like encoders
that are being run on the entire data
set they're run on each split or
fold separately
so you can you can kind of stay blind
from the test if that if that helps
answer the question
and just to you know one last bit on
that like if you
are running and you're you're eventually
going to want to see the test data right
but if you're if you're doing like 30
runs on just
train invalidation and only then once
you've got like good
performing parameters you start applying
it to the test holdout set
then you haven't really designed your
model you're just kind of waiting for a
hit on your model
that catches and learns well and you're
not really architecting it around the
test set
you're kind of getting lucky with a run
and there's even a repeat
count so you can run this same model
like
10 times or three times just to
give it a chance to actually learn well
great any other questions coming up for
anyone
all right looks like we're probably oh
b wilson are there any specific
limitations of scale
yes absolutely um so
when when i ran the jupiter 2021 survey
i was really blown away that more people
weren't using cloud clusters
the majority of the analysis being done
was performed on
um local um desktops
or hpc's and servers so people were just
kind of stuck with what they've got
and this works in that scenario 100 but
like
in in the future i'd like to have a
cloud api where you could just kind of
like offload
once you have your batch of jobs
designed you could just kind of blast
them into the cloud
they all run in parallel and the time it
takes to run one model you could pull it
down
but for now yeah just cues up the jobs
and you know
you run them after getting a cup you um
take the trash out and
you've got your you've got your models
but yeah it's going to be
limited to the resources that you have
on your computer